i think as many of you are watching this
i will either be
on my way up driving to burlington
vermont
or already at the aplareno woodblock
conference
in burlington vermont which runs from
the 4th to the 7th
of august and that's what i'm beginning
my
my month with and that's what i actually
am going to begin this this discussion
of july and august with
this is the july august update for
my channel where i tell you a little bit
about what i did during july
recap in case you missed anything and
then
what i'm more excited about what i'm
going to be doing or hope to be doing in
in august so july was
kind of a up and down month um
i had a lot of people email
or message me or or send comments
i'd mentioned that i had lyme's disease
and uh
that i had to take the antibiotic
doxycycline for that which really does a
number on you
in my last update so i had a lot of
people expressing sympathy about that
i'm happy to say that i'm off the doxie
cycling now
is the limes completely out of my system
who knows you know we never know about
this sort of thing it's the second time
i've had it
um it's just a hazard of living up here
in the hudson valley of new york
not only have i had it twice my dogs
have had it you know it's just
something that's quite common up here it
is debilitating but you know you live
with it
um during july i spent a lot of time
dealing with my students in my online
class that i've been doing for marist my
ethics class where i've got 31 students
runs 10 weeks just wrapping up this this
last week of
august so i'm kind of happy about that i
only did one actual
public speaking gig um i'm continuing
with that lecture series at the
historic kingston library the glimpses
of existence and this time it was on
kafka we had a very spirited discussion
and i think i'm going to follow up on
some of those
things in my sadler's existentialism
updates blog which i
also got got going again in
july i'm kind of happy about that i i
used to blog pretty frequently
and i actually started quite a few blogs
and then you know i got to the point
where i got really busy
with speaking and content production and
youtube videos
and i said i'm just going to put the
blogs on hold and now i want to sort of
take them off of ice and get them going
again
i may actually create some some new ones
just as
resource sites but i'll talk about that
in a little while
so um what did i do during july other
than you know recover from limes and
hang out with my kids
and hang out with with dogs who
thankfully don't have limes and do this
class
um i spent a lot of the time
reading and re-reading and re-reading
what khan so i could finish up this this
uh
long owed article on the con
and ethics which is going to be
appearing in a
volume i think probably
next year so i'll talk more about that
some other time
i worked on a lot of aristotle materials
stuff mostly having to do with handouts
and
guides and thinking about how to apply
things to your own life for for students
and for lifelong learners
and like i pointed out i restarted
sadler's existentialism
updates i did shoot some videos and
release some videos there were some core
concept videos i think i released the
last of the ross videos this month but
i'm not quite
sure because it doesn't show when i
release them but i i also
had some aristotle videos specifically
about aristotle's notions
about justice and nico mccain ethics
book five
so i released most of those i still have
one that i have to release
this month so that's coming up and i
continued with the half hour hegel i
didn't get quite as many of them done as
i would have liked but
um you know it was pretty busy in july
and i did this philoso geek reflections
on the technosphere that's kind of a
mouthful
uh specifically on facebook's experiment
with emotional contagion that came out
then the news about that
and i need to do some follow-up about
that this month and i'll talk about that
i also uh began doing the short clips
the the
question answer things people write in
and
i respond to them in these 10 short
clips i did number 19 this month
so uh what's going on in august august
is a big
month not so much for public speaking
but more for laying the groundwork
and really the first thing that i ought
to say is we're starting to fill up the
calendar
for reason i o that's the the consulting
and content production
and now philosophical counseling
company that that i use for
all of the work that i do we're starting
to fill up the calendar for that so if
you are interested in booking me for a
talk or you want to put
a bug in somebody's ear about bringing
me in to do a talk or a workshop
or to facilitate some discussion now
is the the time to do it so you can
contact me
through google plus through youtube
you know i'm pretty easy to find on the
on the web i think
so what have we got going on so
at the beginning of august i'm going up
to burlington vermont i was invited to
host
a discussion for the oclerno
woodblock conference and i'm going to be
hosting a discussion specifically about
the future of higher ed
it's going to i'll put you i'll put a
link to this so you can you can actually
follow it if you want to
it's going to be a google hangout on air
and
it's got a number of interesting
panelists i i i won't tell you about
them
quite yet you can you know find out that
information by going to plairno's
site which i've got linked to here and
you can see who they are
in any case we're gonna have a really
spirited discussion
um monday the fourth
ten o'clock eastern standard time if i
remember right
about some issues like
is is higher education in america
sustainable what about worldwide
where are things going to go 10 years
from now 20 years from now
how does technology impact um you know
the the changes
the availability the players all these
sorts of things
really fascinating topic so i've got
that coming up
i may be doing a dr sadler's philosophy
forum this month with michael
connell who is a australian comedian a
guy that i've been
talking with quite a bit a guy who's got
some very dry
comedy so if you like that sort of stuff
he's probably right up your alley
i've long had an interest in philosophy
and its connection with humor and comedy
and satire
and so getting the chance to
tap a guy who not only is a comic
and is a funny guy but also knows
something about
philosophy who did a philosophy degree
in in australia
for me is is a you know that that's like
a kid walking into a candy store right
so
i'm really looking forward to that if i
don't manage to
schedule him in it really depends on his
schedule
if i don't manage to schedule him in i
will be doing a dr
sandler's philosophy for forum probably
sometime
in the middle of the month and i think
i'm going to focus it on
existentialism if we don't do comedy
and you know even if we do comedy we
might do some existentialism
so that's part of what's going on um
this is the month that the people who
are associated with the happiness
happens movement have picked out
as happiness month so there's there's an
event on the 8th
happiness happens day and
i'm going to do a special video for that
talking about the nature of happiness
and some some ideas about happiness
um i'm not quite sure what exactly is
is coming up because they don't actually
have it listed on their website
you know precisely what they're going to
do for the eighth happiness happens day
but they they have a lot of interesting
things going on so i
include a link to them as well and then
after all of that i go for the third
week
really the mid part of the the second
week to the third week
of um august i'm heading to switzerland
my wife is enrolled in european graduate
school
this is her second year there if you
don't know about european graduate
school
it's one of the top-notch continental
philosophy
venues and educational institutions it
was actually founded by some of the
you know the big names in in continental
philosophy years and years and years ago
it's a high intensity low residency
program
and so she's working on her her uh her
phd right now
in uh philosophy there and so i'm gonna
go
and join her i'm not quite sure what
i'll be doing i may shoot some videos
while i'm there i may shoot some videos
by the way while i'm in vermont since
you know there'll be some really
pretty backdrops to to to go over
and uh you know but we'll see what
happens in any case
i'm going to be out of the country for a
bit
and hanging out with my wife and meeting
some people that are interested in lacan
derrida
you know nietzsche and heidegger and all
those sorts of people i may do some
talks i don't know we'll see what
happens
um what you're probably more interested
in
what am i going to be bringing out as
far as videos this month
so i mentioned that i have one aristotle
core concept video
yet to uh to release that one is
actually on
can a person do injustice to themselves
so kind of a paradoxical topic
but then i have some plato core concept
videos that i'm working on
uh specifically dealing with the apology
and the credo some of the issues that
are coming up with those
i've got some half hour hegel videos
i'm gonna try to churn them out about
once a week or so
so we can get on track with that and
hopefully get the preface
done sometime this fall
i promised some kafka videos last month
you got one of them
with our my discussion at the library
but i'm going to do some straight out
lecture kafka videos as well
probably restricting myself
although i'm really tempted to do some
other things restricting myself to the
metamorphosis
and the trial and maybe
you know if i get a little exuberant
about it
inside the penal colony which is a story
of his that i find really fascinating
i've gotta i've got some more 10 shorts
that i'm going to
do to answer some questions that have
been rolling in by the way if you're
interested in asking me questions
you got the link to that video where you
can post them
here and then i've got some philoso geek
follow-up stuff to do i i raised some
questions at the very end
of philosophy number eight last month
and now i think it's time for me to get
around to actually exploring those and
and doing that in a bit more detail
what else is going on this month
so i'm turning 44
on the 18th and so if you want to wish
me a happy birthday
in youtube or google plus or facebook or
whatever that that that's all fine
i can't really think of anything i
particularly want for my birthday
so you know i don't know what to say
about that
but um i may actually do a video
44 is not a very important year but the
birthdays are kind of a time to take
stock of
what have you been doing with your life
what are you planning on doing with your
life
do those map on to each other at all
and you know once you get into your 40s
you start thinking a lot more about
these sorts of things
especially since human life expectancy
at least for males in the us
you know tapers off after 78
you start thinking much more seriously
about what have i
actually gotten done so i'll probably do
be doing a bit more of that this
this month today actually by the way is
the
as i'm shooting this is the anniversary
of my my father's death
years and years and years ago so that
kind of puts things in perspective as
well
i don't want to end this on a downer
like that so
what i'll say is i've got a lot of
things going on in august
i started the google help outs that's
something i didn't mention
for july i did a few help outs in july
and really enjoyed them and i think that
the people who use them found them very
useful and helpful and
perhaps even entertaining they gave me
good reviews
so if you're interested in that sort of
thing i've got a link to that
um if you're interested in
seeing me speak or do a workshop
or something along those lines talk to
your local institutions talk to your
local college or university
write the philosophy department say hey
there's this guy that
we'd really like to come in talk to your
local
church or community organization i'm
game to go just about anywhere so long
as i can actually talk about philosophy
in ways that matter to people
and that connect with not just academics
but
but ordinary people and lifelong
learners so if you've got something
along those lines
uh don't be shy i'm i'm pretty
open to uh to doing that that's the
whole reason why we founded reason io
it's to
put philosophy into practice that's part
of the reason i moved up here to the
hudson valley of course the main reason
is to
be with my my wife but that's
that's where we are right now so that's
what's going on
in august that's what happened in july
and that's the wrap up for this month